on average how far into a pitch would
you know it was a pass for me I can
probably know like right off the bat not
saying that to everybody else's skill
set but I know story well enough to know
that a screenwriter doesn't know their
story very well
um but with that being said it also
depends on how you got the pitch right
because if I'm doing this as a favor to
someone I'm going to listen to the
entire thing right and I'm also possibly
gonna now engage with you after the
pitch etc etc even if I know we're never
going to buy this right or it might be
the opposite because I know how you got
here I know we're going to buy it so no
matter what you say
you know what I mean so I don't really
even have to take in all the information
but you know from the script consultant
side of it
it's easy to tell when someone doesn't
know their story but sometimes people
don't know how to pitch and it's not
that they don't know their story and so
this is where I would say the executive
kind of has to put on a script
consultant hat if they care if they want
to bother to do this so that they can
figure out is it that you don't know how
to pitch or you don't know your story or
you just don't really have a story right
by asking the right kind of questions to
get the right kind of answers so these
days I you know I've been in a couple of
pitches lately and they've been more
conversational which I think is really
helpful for the writer right because
writers can be uh introverted right and
they don't want to have to come in here
and present and they might have
something really great to say but it's
just not coming out the way that they
expect it to you know expect it to come
out but to go back to the example about
zombies if we're not taking zombies now
in the first few words out of your mouth
are zombies then I know we're done now
you have the hour so I'm gonna let you
talk but I'm not you know we're not
going to buy this
um I think if I'm confused throughout
your pitch I now have to ask myself if
I'm willing to do the work of not being
confused because it's going to be my job
to go in the Next Room to pitch it to
the rest of the company you know what I
mean if I'm this confused about what
you're giving to me then I can't
possibly be that interested in it and
for the most part you know executives
are looking for what fits for their
brand and their mandate Etc but they're
also looking for what excites them
because they're listening to pictures
all the time the reading screenplays all
the time so they're looking for
something that excites them so if
they're listening and whatever it is
you're pitching doesn't excite them then
they probably already know we're not
going to do this or because they've been
listening so many pitches and because
they've been reading so many screenplays
they already know they have five of
those
already in development so they're not
going to buy this one right because they
already have that in development so
there are a lot of things that can play
into why someone would pass on something
but I think most Executives know pretty
quickly that this is probably something
they're going to pass on even if they do
have to do the rest of the pomping
circumstance well you said
um it could be a they don't know how to
pitch
and it could be also B they don't have a
story how many times did someone come in
and they really didn't have a story lots
of times
lots of times now with that being said
that's without my script consultant hat
on to then ask them the questions that
are necessary so I can pull it out of
them right because if you are a
professional writer I would like to
assume I don't have to do that that you
would be able to come in and find ask
for a log line you can tell me clearly
in two sentences what your screenplay is
about right but not everyone can do that
and so if you've been talking at me for
45 minutes and then on the end of it I
can't give you a log line back you don't
have a story
right maybe you've got a great idea you
know what I mean and your great idea was
zombies right but what are the zombies
doing
who are we rooting for the zombies or is
there you know a police officer you know
who is you know looking for his family
and dealing with zombies while he's
doing that because he's trying to get
back to his wife that's what the story
is but if you spend all your time
talking to me only about zombies and how
cool they are and how fast they run and
what they can and cannot do but you
never told me about the heart you never
told me about what I'm physically going
to be watching what what goals or
problems they're trying to solve then
I'm going to say to myself there's no
story here
and maybe there is and you just forgot
to tell me because you got so excited
about zombies and talked about it for 45
minutes and so that's what I mean by
well then you just don't know how to
pitch right you haven't learned that
skill and it's a skill set so it's not
easy to learn and again it's not
something that people are out there
teaching you know what I'm saying so
usually it's trial and error and this is
again why having
um you know a script consultant since I
exist now but having a manager or an
agent and people who you can practice
with people who should know that
executive well enough to know when you
go in this room this is what you want to
do right like that's kind of a a I'm not
going to say it's their purpose but hey
if they have sent people in this room to
pitch for this person before they should
be able to give you some pointers right
on what you should do when you're in
that room so I think it could be either
of the above but a lot of times when
I've done like more more so pitch
contests if I've been like a judge in a
pitch contest or something like that
um it's happened also when I was a
network executive but more so when I'm
uh at a like a pitch contest or
something like that and the amount of
people who come up in pitch and never
get to their story
they never get there or I can tell they
don't know what it is like they got a
great idea you know what I mean but they
just haven't quite uh connected all of
the dots so that there's an actual story
and some people are great presenters you
know I've seen many people that they're
amazing at presenting something maybe
not executing it and then vice versa
right and and those executors just
freeze up and and oftentimes aren't
given a chance but I I just saying most
people don't know how to fish yeah and
that's what makes it unfair right
because you could have a great story but
if you don't know how to present it
then the people don't know what they're
buying and then now it got passed on or
maybe you're a great presenter and you
came in and you did something that got
me excited and now I like you and now I
want to work with you and then I get the
screenplay and I go
hahaha
what is this right so you know it sucks
in that way that you know you don't know
which thing you're getting which is why
I say you know with my script consultant
hat on I know what questions to ask so
that I can understand if they know what
their story is you know what I mean and
from there I can then decide okay they
actually know what they're doing or they
don't know what they're doing they got a
great idea now do I want to sign up for
them not knowing what they're doing
because if I'm an executive that's more
work on me it's more work on me if I
sign up for this knowing you don't know
what you're doing but I really like your
idea which is why sometimes you'll then
be given your check as a screenwriter
sent on your way and then we'll bring in
a more experienced writer to take it to
where it needs to go because we can tell
that you didn't know what you you know
what you were doing or you wouldn't be
able to take it where it needs to go
um I believe it was a Ozark and I can't
think of his name now but uh the Creator
was someone who had worked in features
forever but he knew he didn't know TV so
he didn't expect to go in and then run
the show he knew we need to bring
someone in here who can do TV who knows
series and that's not me and so a lot of
times we'll take it personally as
writers because we're sensitive right
we'll take it personally and we'll think
it's it's me woe is me blah blah blah
but it's like you have to know what your
skill sets are you have to know that
this is a collaborative process and you
have to know there's a there are
millions of dollars being spent it's
okay if someone comes in and grabs the
Baton from you to take it to the next
place it's okay
how does a writer with no connections
build a relationship with a studio
executive you know there used to be like
no way for you to do that right the good
thing is social media exists now
if people are on social media I always
tell people Twitter is probably the best
place for you to be a lot of people who
are on Twitter are on there because they
want to be open especially since the
pandemic people are on there they're
reading stuff they're talking back to
you you know what I mean I have a client
who was staffed from Twitter right so
Twitter is a great place to just kind of
build community you don't want to go on
there and immediately respond to someone
and say hey I'm a writer I have a
screenplay come read it it's not that
it's literally relationship building
follow the people that you're interested
in following
and respond like a human being who's
just on Twitter if they say something
about their dog respond about your dog
you know if they're saying something
about their kids respond about your
experience if they then start talking
about their show now hopefully you're
watching that show and that's why you're
following them in the first place you
can start saying some stuff about the
show and things that you like in the
blah blah blah and then one day they'll
say hey I'm gonna read some screenplays
today
send them and now because you've been
interacting as a human being before then
they're going oh this person because
you're on social media we tend to think
we know each other because we've been on
there you know kind of interacting as
our handles and they'll go oh this
person is sending their script I'll read
it right doesn't mean it'll turn into
anything but maybe it will
um outside of that you know there are a
lot of different uh organizations now
who give you opportunities to meet with
people some of them are are paid uh they
have fees so you just have to kind of
look and look into that to see if that's
something you want to budget
um but there are uh different companies
that give you an opportunity to do quick
little meetings quick little general
meetings like I said or pitch Fest where
you get to kind of you know be in front
of people
um
I don't know if executives are attending
film festivals like they used to except
for the big huge ones right they're all
at Sundance you can go to Sundance go to
Sundance right because now you can just
kind of hang out and see who you can
meet again this is not walking around
shoving your screenplay into people's
faces they don't get much time off and
they're not even off while they're at
Sundance because they have to go to the
stuff you know what I mean they have to
see what's happening they might even
have other meetings they have to be on
while they're there so the few moments
where they are sitting around having a
beer that's what they want to be doing
so just be a human being and just get to
know them they know why you're there you
know they know that you want to be a
filmmaker of some sort it'll probably
come up in conversation and then after
you see that oh we're actually
connecting on all of these other things
there might be an opportunity for that
person to give you their card or for you
to say hey I would love to send some
stuff your way if you're open to it and
if they say they're open that's your
chance get the card and email the stuff
you know what I mean
um but you know other than that
it's the same thing when it comes to
agents and managers you know you just
kind of have to get out there and
advocate for yourself and do your own
thing and when it's time they'll come
they'll find you you know what I mean
but at least nowadays social media
exists in a way where you can interact
with people
um again you're not shoving your work in
front of their faces but you're
interacting with them so that you can
get to know them as a person as much as
you can on social media right and then
see if you can build a relationship from
there so that when you are ready to
pitch something you're already to show
them something then it's not a cold
email anymore or it's not a cold ask
anymore it's a little bit warmer
and and I like what you said about card
I mean I was wondering do we even still
have cards anymore but yeah it sounds
like it's still a useful tool yeah and
then and it's also more subtle than why
don't you look me up and and one thing
too having a website like you have a
website that's fully fleshed out there's
things you can find bio this that
sometimes I see people it's something's
under construction yeah it's it's coming
soon and then it never comes so yeah you
know it's just having that there yeah I
think it's I think it's really odd uh
that La is still a card place when I
came back in 2018 I was like I'm not
making cards it's 2018 we'll be able to
find each other in some way and then I
would go to all of these networking
events and everyone had cards and I was
like people are still collecting cards
you know but yeah it it happens when you
get your studio executive job or your
network executive job and you go through
your whole you know onboarding process
They're Gonna Give You cards
and people are walking around handing
them out like that's that's what they do
um they're not going to tell you to look
them up they don't want you to randomly
contact them in some other way this is
the way they want you to contact them
um and and you will and that's how you
can you know continue on with the
relationship or at least send them the
thing that they ask you to send them
um to see where you know it's going to
go